I have never felt closer to mom I'm in
the exact same place that she was all
those years ago you're pregnant yeah
yeah tonight
it's a night for celebration come on
let's get this show on the road I was
told you couldn't come I'm a spontaneous
person no you're not no I'm not it takes
three great men to create such a woman
you never did ask you guys what happened
when you met my mother
I don't know it may feature holes but
the world is wide I want to make some
memories there's an island Calla Carrie
people used to think if you sailed on
from there you'd fall off the edge of
the world
sounds like the place for me I'm Bo I'm
Donna he is literally the handsomest man
in the world suffer the sky
well this whole place is incredible I
think we should stay here together may
the rest of our lives be the best of our
lives just tell me you didn't invite
your grandmother Wicked Witch of the
West I've decided to commit to being a
grandmother grandma you weren't invited
that's the best kind of party little
girls my soul mate may actually be
calmed then y must be wine all three of
us are grandfather's that's that
[Music]
look what you've done with the place she
wanted to make her mum proud if she
hasn't done that all her life
[Music]
we can't tell anybody about the baby yet
I just told bills yeah and I told Harry
I told many many people got about to
become a grandmother great-grandmother
I'm living that out of the bio
[Music]